this is the technical difficulties were
playing citation needed adjoining the
studio today he reads books you know
it's Chris Joel I don't think there's
anything left to say everybody's
favorite go around Gary Brannen putting
the eaten in the greetin and bam smell
means at my grey clothes up in front of
me I have an article from Wikipedia and
these folks can't sick thank you Gary
these folks can't see it every fact we
get right there's a point and a ding and
the special prize for particular dancers
which is today's article is the swarm
film starring Michael Caine good grief a
point straight away
thank you it's about a swarm of killer
bees somewhere in the Midwest of America
Michael Caine plays a scientist I do
believe so Gary's won the show but um
yes Michael Caine plays dr. Bradford
crane which aphid just sounds like food
crane hello Bradford cranes you've got a
nine-ton 14-ton and morris michael why
yeah yeah I don't quite understand our
cranes gonna help you with this war
would be unless you want us to lift a
tree or something where are ya America
no no we'd all go that far
giant jam sandwich yeah did you have
challenged M sandwich when you were
little
no our jam sandwiches an ace book is
about Oh a swarm but of wasps that
comment an attacker town and sting them
air on his fat bald pate so the Baker
giant loaf of bread making enormous jam
sandwich trap all the wasps in the jam
and then crush them to death with
another loaf another slice from the loaf
and then in the sequel a giant eating
it's an old Stang out man
oh dang stank out yeah so well sometimes
are they all staying out
or its use for a crane in that situation
it is I dancing Joe how else are you
gonna flop your second slice of bread
down why did they make a bread loaf why
don't they just make a giant bread roll
because otherwise you've got a look
you've got all the slices in the giant
loaf I didn't mara was about that's not
a gemstone which are they jam roll
that's true I don't feel good drive my
jam Jake stick the thing is if you have
to phone up Rolls Royce and say I want a
J I want a Rolls Royce covered in Jam
they do it for you if you pay enough
horrendous bespoke cost but yes they do
it yeah they probably would they use a
real Jam or a synthetic Jam that would
last a long time so what I bring my
memory what I am what I'm thinking is
that rolls would probably create a
see-through layer on the outside of the
body panel enabling you to trap some
very good high-quality Jam between the
body panel and the plastic panel thereby
leaving you with one coating of
excellent Jam that strikes me as the
rolls-royce way that brings us to the
finest of the rolls-royce as the silver
shred silver shred is a lemon jam the
Silver Ghost is a car that is the most
obscure dog I got it
unlike to a few seconds I didn't get
either part of it
the swarm gentlemen are guessing it's a
Michael Caine film it's from his it's a
living stage of his career I could not
put it better myself
there's some great lines in Erzurum
you've got Michael K if you don't get
those doors closed this scientific is
decision it's got to be full of bees
that sounds like a film on so as soon as
he just waited for my cook a good beat
he has been stung to death by bees and
also slim pickins really yeah brilliant
awesome playing a redneck rather than
account well I'm glad he extended his
range he wasn't typecast as it is yeah
you could play Appalachia or the West is
it
oh damn man but very them some chops
oxf is big telling gallon hat please
fall it's the phrase covered in bees
coming to them yeah will do because
people do get covered in bees and then
stank to death by bees spider clever
bees that can work their way into our
air-conditioning units and stuff the
girl yeah clever girl
mmm-hmm there's some lovely plot points
in here dr. Krim self inject an
experimental bee venom antidote the
trial proves fake he kills himself yes
cuz he got our jet valve dammit oh and
then runs in the Sun bees
powder Andrews is convinced that his
plan tees nuclear power plant can be on
the attacks of the bees at that moment
the alarm sound the bees invade the
plant yes I'm sorry I felt a scientific
base you right it's a nuclear power
plant there where the bees are gonna get
into the power plant and cause it to
explode they do this boilers they did
because I think Michael cares like you
know it the only way it's worth about is
to walk around a nuclear explosion and
it kind of everyone kind of looked
around I kind of put we're in a nuclear
power station can't your face that's not
actually how they defeat the swarm yeah
oh baby water I know that's terrific
oh you nearly there how they lure them
out to see how do you James ham sandwich
go to an aircraft carrier because the
alarm system was what attracted them in
the first place the alarm went off the
power plant the bees were attracted to
alarms apparently
that's also did you reduce doesn't say
let's be more did we do that
I was it didgeridoo full of bees nice
just a swarm of didgeridoo DS say you
get the two confused he's asked me pain
toys or there's some other history to
this film it was released originally at
two just shy of two hours so extra forty
minutes of footage added for release in
the 1980s what what format 3d no way was
released for home for home distribution
in the 1980s laserdisc ladies a strong
laserdisc of bees tell me that that was
the first Michael Caine film out on any
kind of home video probably not a get
car I'll never mind that bees but it's
great at that stage of disaster films
where you know you've done earthquakes
you've done infernos you've done ships
been turned upside down by tsunamis you
know the stage of Belize there are
actually many more films here about
large swarms of bees get to get some
names the swarm to this time there's no
Michael Daly viewpoint because I think
of remaking this war Oh who's gonna play
the Michael Caine pies okay yeah
hopefully they'll get Tom Hardy he's in
quite oh yeah and he can act which is
said that somebody has been hitting the
ball to the ball so what the cheese is
coming to the ball that the boos why I
really wanted in in that film was from
the take the mask of Bane and he still
talks the same without it so they pull
the swarm out to see what do they do to
it it's quite hard to kill a swarm of
bees they don't nuke it hmm
flamethrowers mmm right they just spray
it with insect repellent
you're closer oh did I fire a missile
that's it
um they downs the water with oil and set
the swarm ablaze oh my cuz bees can't go
upwards
a bit higher dogs if the heat would make
them rise so they pop like popcorn
this B is done
days clouds be popke honey flavor pop
yeah tears of honey
the the final point of the film that
domdom its Michael came wondering about
that whether they've finally succeeded
whether it's a permanent victory um he
decides it if we use a I can't deal
Michael Caine impression I've so I'm
gonna put some Gary if we use our time
wisely the world might just survive if
we use our time wisely the world might
just survive you don't even see them
moving in yeah I wish but he's got to
look over a hill and then hopefully a
semi or a single big camera crash zooms
on it but uh and then the end question
are cool
alright I'm gonna do a quick fire round
here blimey name me some animals on you
point for each one that actually does
have an invasion movie holders night the
shrews or something killer shriyak yes
national and many horses no
astonishingly I've got no a Wikipedia
does not know sheep yeah yes black she
exists the birds yeah yeah
no he's mean in the 60s 60s group the
birds du Clark's coming you look it at
the playground everything turn still
being a bird as well
yes yeah you don't you obeyed leaving
that good you can see go hey at the end
of the show congratulations Gary you
obviously win this one for just know
everyone yes Mercedes are you in up doc
what husband Chris Joel killed him you
guys came late runnin
I cry I've been dumped Scott how's the
end of the series once again next time
leaves an oily residue when she gets hot
oh and it's naturally gray in color are
the one thing I do know that war happens
we've got battered chips whoa
I took very different reactions out that
one you can see and I'm with Matt on
this
thank you for watching citation needed
that was the last one in this run we've
just thrown some more language files
videos thanks for help with that matter
things you might not know will continue
and there may be some quiz stuff soon
but there will be more of this okay it's
talking to us
you